[Music]
the fun of a runaway train
just affair
remember this part from Red Dead
Redemption the part where John Marston
rides into Mexico to the evocative
lyrics of Jose Gonzales the part where
the world felt like a character in
itself like it was reacting to your
arrival and although other players would
experience this same moment it was
ultimately yours and yours alone
Rockstar has made its entire sequel
about moments like this with Red Dead
Redemption to the studio has created a
responsive world that recognizes the
player adapts and yields appropriate
results Rockstar has made the America of
1899 a character of its own so to speak
it is nuanced and fickle
it contains multitudes and it represents
a significant leap in open-world design
[Music]
it's on
[Music]
at Eurogamer Expo 2017 Bioshock director
Ken Levine took the stage to talk about
his career and his new studio ghost
story games was created from the remains
of irrational games early last year and
it signaled a shift from linear shooters
to more emergent narratives so there's a
term we have of the studio which is
called radical recognition and when that
means is if the gamer does something the
game should recognize it and the game
should talk about it like there was a
thing back in System Shock 1 you make
this jump over this pit and there's a
line they recorded in a part of show
tangos nice jump that was a moment which
I never seen before with the game
recognized some just think you did in
the world right and so one of the most
important things about what we're doing
now is this concept of radical
recognition in short ghost story wants
to show the player that the game world
cares when asked about good examples of
this tenant in recent games Levine
mentioned 2014's Middle Earth shadow of
Mordor famed for its dynamic nemesis
system
shadow of Mordor creates personalities
for its army of Orcs based on their
interactions with the player finish off
an orc captain with an arrow in his head
and he'll return later with a metal
plate attached to his skull he'll also
remember the encounter and taunt you
accordingly
to paraphrase Levine the Nemesis system
is a focused rudimentary approach to
that idea of radical recognition
shadow of Mordor pays attention to the
player's actions and it responds in turn
I can't wait for Levine to play Red Dead
Redemption too much like rockstars
previous titles Red Dead 2 has a
scripted main storyline with concrete
characters and a linear narrative it
follows one Arthur Morgan as he escapes
the long arm of the law in the American
Wild West but after 50 hours in
rockstars Western it's clear the team
wanted to create a world with that same
kind of digital memory Levine described
unlike rockstars previous game Red Dead
2 really seems to care about your
existence more than that it seems to
care about how you choose to exist if
you act like an outlaw the game will
make you feel like one
if you try your best to be a decent
person the world's inhabitants will
treat you accordingly to give a good
example I'll use one of my favorite
personal anecdotes early in my
playthrough an npc recognized Arthur
from his past not wanting him to alert
the authorities I naturally gave chase
the only problem was in all the
confusion I took somebody else's horse I
caught up to the man threatened him and
I felt safer than I had before nothing
felt too out of the ordinary but then I
got back to town and this is what
happened next it was that return and
that man recognizing me and recognizing
my semi good deed that really made the
whole thing shine this kind of story
isn't new The Witcher 3 Excel that
reminding you of choices you made
throughout Geralt adventure but these
little incidental reminders happen
constantly in Red Dead 2 they occur so
often that they become the norm it was
still impressive don't get me wrong but
it just didn't stand out anymore it felt
natural it felt organic but the fun in
Red Dead 2 comes from experiencing those
moments yourself so I'll let you do just
that
we've navigated countless branching
narratives and games we've explored
massive sandbox landscapes we've built
an army of custom characters with
distinct personalities powers and styles
by now video games have developed a
strong grasp on player choice what most
games don't firmly grasp however is
consequence and really choice is nothing
without consequence and that's why Red
Dead 2 is so impressive it regularly
shows us the aftermath of the decisions
we make and how they affect the world
and the people around us these
consequences can be something relatively
small the town drunk getting pissed at
you for staring too long for example or
it can be something more pervasive if
you constantly rob stagecoaches or kill
innocent people the authorities
recognize you as an outlaw you'll not
only be wanted in the map's respective
provinces but townsfolk avoid you store
owners are on alert and all in all
inhabitants are just less trusting Red
Dead 2 not only gives you the choice to
be evil but makes you feel evil as a
result I recently read about a program
at the University of Copenhagen called
Super Mario evolution it records various
play styles in the flash game infinite
mario bros by compiling these results it
then builds new levels to encourage or
oppose these play styles in the abstract
for the research groups paper Julian -
Elias outlined one of the major benefits
of developing such a program while there
is limited demand in the games industry
for higher performing opponents in most
games genre x' there is a demand for
more interesting npcs opponents allies
sidekicks etc for better ways of
adapting the game to the player so
although it's impactful to design a game
that can make the player react it's
another challenge entirely to make a
world that reacts to the player but like
the devs that worked on shadow of Mordor
and the researchers behind Super Mario
evolution Rockstar Games knows the value
of a reactive world Red Dead - builds
expectations so well that even when I'm
doing something menial I feel as if the
world is paying attention I came across
this abandoned wagon recently and as I
took the time to investigate
I felt genuine paranoia maybe someone
who's waiting to ambush me or maybe
there's a corpse nearby or maybe there's
something sinister hiding behind that
claw
flapping in the wind but there was
nothing there it was just an abandoned
wagon I don't know why it was there or
whose it was but regardless I continued
on my way unable to shake the feeling
that someone or something was watching
me that whole time we come into every
game with an element of curiosity but
this is one of those few times I felt as
if a game was curious about me as I
mentioned there are times when Red Dead
2 borders on eerie but there are other
times this radical recognition results
in excitement or hilarity at one point I
climbed a water tower to avoid the
authorities canvassing the crime scene
below they noticed me and this is what
happened what you know about it know by
this point Red Dead 2 had built up its
world so well that I not only foresaw
the consequences of the murders I
committed but also knew my best chance
of avoiding them what followed was a
memorable story involving a tense
standoff and a really dumb deputy we
know that every form of entertainment
requires a willing suspension of
disbelief we acknowledge that we're
staring at a screen or reading words on
a page and we surrender to the story
being told it's part of the psychology
of enjoying media it's an agreement
between the creator and the viewer that
there is artifice here but we'll ignore
it as best we can and let our
imaginations do their things Red Dead
Redemption 2 tries to ask less of you in
this regard than almost any other game
I've played I always know I'm playing a
game of course but I will say it is
magnitudes easier to suspend that
disbelief because I expect NPCs to
recognize me I expect my actions to have
ripple effects I expect the world to
change as I change alongside it no
shortage of hyperbole has been spent on
describing open-world games for the last
decade they've transported us and
explored player agency doing their best
to disguise their boundaries and fill in
the cracks before we notice them we use
terms such as immersive dynamic living
and breathing in many cases games have
come close to actually earning these
badges but I'm not sure I've played a
game that's come as close as Red Dead
Redemption to
it's a masterclass in writing animation
and most of all world design it's a
stunning example of how open worlds can
encourage certain types of behaviors yes
but also how they can react to certain
types of behavior it's a towering
achievement and we'll be talking about
it for a long time
[Music]